Ana: Después de 1949, Costa Rica entra en un ciclo que muchos recuerdan como edad del Estado desarrollista. La palabra clave es socialdemocracia.
Mateo: Socialdemocracia en sentido preciso: democracia política, economía de mercado, pero con Estado fuerte para corregir desigualdades, producir bienes públicos y garantizar salud, educación, pensiones y vivienda.
Ana: El PLN se funda en 1951 y se vuelve fuerza dominante de la segunda mitad del siglo XX. Figueres, Orlich, Facio, Oduber; nombres que mezclan política, intelectuales y proyecto institucional.
Mateo: El desarrollismo se apoya en sustitución de importaciones: proteger industria nacional, invertir en infraestructura, crédito estatal, empresas públicas. La idea era que el país no podía depender solo de exportar productos primarios.
Ana: El ICE es emblema de ese modelo. Electrificación, telecomunicaciones, cobertura nacional. Es el Estado no solo regulando, sino construyendo capacidad material.
Mateo: Y CODESA representa el punto máximo de intervención estatal directa. Empresas públicas en sectores productivos, apuestas industriales, empleo, pero también pérdidas y endeudamiento.
Ana: Durante los sesenta y setenta, el Estado social se expande: CCSS universalizando cobertura, INA, IMAS, INVU. Salud, formación técnica, ayuda social, vivienda. El país mejora indicadores sociales de manera notable.
Mateo: Pero el modelo tenía límites. Endeudamiento externo, inflación, proteccionismo, empresas ineficientes. La crisis latinoamericana de la deuda en los años ochenta golpea fuerte.
Ana: Entonces aparece la otra palabra: ajuste. Programas de Ajuste Estructural, FMI, Banco Mundial, reducción del déficit, devaluación, apertura comercial, privatización de empresas estatales y reforma financiera.
Mateo: Para defensores, era medicina amarga pero necesaria para evitar colapso. Para críticos, trasladó costos a sectores vulnerables y debilitó partes del Estado social. Las dos lecturas conviven hasta hoy.
Ana: Costa Rica se adhiere al GATT en 1990 y luego firma tratados de libre comercio. El CAFTA-DR incluso pasa por referéndum en 2007, con un país partido casi por la mitad.
Mateo: El régimen de zonas francas es central en esta etapa. Exenciones, simplificación, PROCOMER, atracción de inversión. El Estado deja de producir directamente muchas cosas y pasa a facilitar exportaciones.
Ana: Intel en 1996 se vuelve símbolo: alta tecnología, diversificación, presión sobre educación técnica, efecto demostración. Costa Rica ya no quiere ser solo café y banano; quiere integrarse a cadenas globales.
Mateo: Luego vienen servicios modernos: centros compartidos, finanzas, diseño, tecnología, logística. Y con telecomunicaciones, la Ley de 2008 abre el monopolio del ICE a competencia privada vinculada al CAFTA.
Ana: El balance no es simple. La apertura diversifica exportaciones y atrae inversión, pero también crea dualismo: un sector global dinámico y un sector interno menos productivo.
Mateo: Además, las exenciones de zonas francas tensionan el financiamiento del Estado social. ¿Cómo sostener salud, educación e infraestructura si parte del sector más dinámico tributa bajo reglas especiales?
Ana: Entonces no es una historia de Estado vencido por mercado. Es una mutación: el Estado pasa de empresario y productor a regulador, facilitador, negociador internacional y garante social bajo presión fiscal.
Mateo: Y deja preparada la última gran pregunta institucional: cuando el mercado global acelera y la política se fragmenta, ¿quién protege la Constitución social? En Costa Rica, buena parte de esa respuesta la dará la Sala IV.